German and French troops fighting
side-by-side just like these soldiers of
the franco-german brigade
if things go John Claude yonkers way
this will be the future of European
defence in an interview the president of
the EU Commission called for a European
army it's not a new idea and it has many
supporters in Germany even in the
defense ministry owners of not males
bone we want to expand this cooperation
between different European armies so
that we can utilize our joint potential
especially considering the monetary
restraints of the mines I'm engaged
cutting so calm if member countries
jointly order military equipment such as
tanks they could save billions each year
it's an important argument especially
when there's a crisis but the Ukraine
conflict seems to be the main reason the
joint army idea is resurfacing right now
Germany's opposition Left Party rejects
the idea dkh the Left Party thinks
Yungas suggestion is a bad idea
it's definitely aimed at Russia we
believe the EU should conduct a peaceful
foreign policy people share also
political authority there are many
obstacles to the creation of a European
army every country would have to allow
Brussels to make decisions about its
soldiers that includes Germany we're
currently only Parliament can determine
whether to deploy Bundeswehr troops
abroad